herzlich willkommen zurück bei sie denn
wir sind heute wieder in berlin und bei
uns ist francesco francesco woher kommst
du hier komme aus italien
wir haben heute ein thema da geht es
wieder ein bisschen um die aussprache im
deutschen wir haben gemerkt wir reden ja
mit vielen von euch die deutsch lernen
es gibt so ein konsonant mit dem haben
viele leute probleme weil es den in
vielen sprachen nicht gibt oder der
anders ausgesprochen wird und das ist
dass wir geben wir ein beispiel
francesco wie sagt man in italienisch
radio also radio ja mit dieser ach das
ist vorne gewinnen bei uns wird das ihr
wird hinten gewillt im rachen radio grau
und wir gehen heute mal raus francesco
fragt die leute auf der straße ob sie
ihnen helfen können und wir fragen
einfach mal die deutschen hier
ob die uns helfen können euch zu zeigen
wie man dass er im deutschen ausspricht
los geht's
[Musik]
hier sei nichts zu tun
danke das erhöhe
genauso mit dem mit dem rollen leicht
also könntest du mir bitte erklären wie
die deutschen denn er aussprechen
der rv rot-rot ich versuche dass dann
hinten zur
rolle ok also versuchen den rachen mit
der zunge hinten im einklang zu bringen
mit vibrationen könntest du mir bitte
erklären die deutschen den er
aussprechen
also ich glaube dass die deutschen gar
nicht richtig merken wie sie das er
aussprechen
es ist sowas wie so fuhren also wie sehr
man wenn man die tauben nachmachen
lehrer
ich denke normalerweise über wörter
nicht so nahe weil ich spreche ja
einfach weil ich das seit 15 jahren so
machen und könnte sie mir bitte erklären
wie sie denn er aussprechen aber wichtig
keine ahnung dass ich spreche ja
italiana comic charaktere internet
jahren in italien para la
wie brot oder brote ja aber die rollen
halt nicht so also ganz normales niveau
massiv italiener passe ich würde
vorschlagen ist einfach ein glas wasser
ok ok beschluss nicht unter sondern
mussten den gaumen musst du wackeln
lassen beim reden also hier den hinteren
raum und mir ein paar gebiete vorlesen
ja ganz normal auf deutsche mutter
mutter mutter mutter
mutter also da hört man dass er fast gar
nicht ein lehrer ist es eigentlich nur
das mittlere was sie hören
am schluss ist es ein offener mund
lehrer aber dadurch dass er nicht mehr
gesprochen es gibt also glaube ich so
gut wie keinen deutschen auf der gut
deutsch also hochdeutsch spricht der
lehrer am schuss weil ein rollendes r sa
das schafft also an ihn verschluckt mehr
oder weniger das ist einfach in der
sprache so drin bei uns dass es quasi
strom ist lehrer genau das beispiel
ausgleich so beispiel das mittlere er
hört man jetzt merke ich das mal das
wird er gar nicht richtig aussprechen
sondern immer mehr so hattest du das
nicht bemerkt noch nicht mehr leer leer
[Musik]
mehr mehr
und das meer wobei das r bei mir dann
auch nicht gerollt ist aber man spricht
sie so ganz ohne zu rollen aus leer
aber es gibt kein r in die auf frage
oder mehr ist auch irgendwie
verschwindet auch so mehr mehr mehr und
mehr genau das schwer
ich wäre schwer mehr ja schon wieder
mehr verregnet verregnet verregnet
verregnet er einmal verregnet war
verregnet also doppel eher verregnet ja
da spricht man es tatsächlich so aus ich
glaube es kommt einfach darauf an ob das
er am ende ist oder nicht gerne gerne
denn dann gerne gerne da hört man dass
er fast nicht gerne gar nicht gar nicht
gar nicht da sagt man zum beispiel nur
geht und das erwartete weil es am
schluss ist dann geht man von dem er
fast schon zu den über gar nicht gar
nicht gar nicht gar nicht
aber früher wird mehr verließen also
ohne da ist es ärgerlich zu deutsch
ausgesprochen wie bei den anderen
wörtern 333 da wird das zweite auch
ausgesprochen
früher das war jetzt ein bisschen zu
stark betont von mir ich merke dass
schon gewicht das vorlese dass ich schon
meine auf sprache verändere rührei und
brötchen brötchen hat man es auf jeden
fall viel besser als in der fiktiven
brötchen brötchen also brötchen brötchen
da hat man es ihr wieder gut oder bei
radio radio radio sieht anders aus dann
merkt man schon dass er am anfang
radio das merke ich jetzt drüber
sprechen sehr schwer für sie es ist
schwer okay
rund rund rund weil es eben am anfang
ist der hund und ° ° ° ° ° ° ° machst du
da sie magst du dieses grau grau grau
genau das ist jetzt in der kehle grau
grau grau
da wird es ausgesprochen und board halb
verschluckt wieder also um 50 prozent
erhöht ist das ungefähr mit wort
gebraucht wort wort frage frage frage
frage rühren rühren rühren rühren rühren
rat rat rat das ist ich gebe da einen
guten rat lernen sie deutschland haben
sie in der welt vorteile
ja da wird ein langes angesprochen und
dann kommt das ja auch fläche zum tragen
radio rat und tat
rath und rat rod francesco kannst du
jetzt das heraus sprechen ja ein
bisschen besser auf jeden fall sehr gut
und francesco ist übrigens nicht nur
easy germans zuschauer und jemand der
deutsch lernt er ist auch ein esel
englisches produzent du produzierst
nämlich italien in italien riss in
welcher stadt
genau in mailand und so was könnt ihr
auch machen wenn ihr lust hat mal eure
sprache oder kultur zu zeigen
dann geht doch mal auf unserer website
easy - languages dort ort dort findet
ihr raus wie man bei uns ein co producer
wird und wie ihr die sie german in eurer
sprache machen machen könnt danke fürs
zuschauen wir möchten euch noch mal
einladen
wenn ihr lust habt übungen zu bekommen
das ist ganz neu zu unserer episode dann
werdet bitte ein patch 1 bei uns erkennt
für 1 dollar pro woche mitglied werden
und bekommt dann zu den videos jede
woche vokabel listen übungen und vieles
mehr
guck mal hier rein wachsen danke fürs
zuschauen und danke dir francesco danke
dir carina bis nächste woche